well dozens of Democrats in Congress
have said that they would gladly support
impeachment of the president some of
them are there tonight some of them were
not well there'd be surprises for us as
we watch you may have noticed that many
women in the room are wearing white this
evening why are they doing that and
Henry has the answer to almost any
question you could conceivably ask and
he joins us now to answer well her
that photo on the left shows it very
well a lot of rank-and-file House
Democrats they're wearing white and
we're told it's because they've
organized with Speaker Nancy Pelosi a so
called white out they did some of this
as well I mean they said what will they
be seeing tonight I have not been able
to confirm any specific songs okay but
what I can tell you is that they did
this during the Cavanaugh hearings a
little bit as well it's a sign they say
these Democrats of supporting all women
uh-huh and they want to show the
president clearly who will be looking
straight at them that they support women
now it's interesting because we've got
excerpts from the president's remarks
and at one point he says all Americans
can be proud that we have more women in
the workforce than ever before so that's
only one quick excerpt so clearly the
White House knew maybe something like
this was coming and he's going to
address it that he supports women in the
workforce he wants equal pay those kinds
of things to just kind of say look this
is for show obviously and it also is
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez is one of the
organizers of this because she's in
social media posing with her guest
tonight who she gave a ticket to and it
is the activist who confronted Senator
Jeff Flake in that elevator during the
Kavanagh confirmation process over
sexual assault issues so this is the one
we're gonna yell did flake and scared
and had a video camera in tow
essentially and it it went viral and all
of that and so political points are
being made they're also going to have
elsewhere in the house gallery former
employees of various Trump golf courses
who were found to potentially have
problems with their legal status now
Democrats are bringing people here
illegally who worked at Trump's they're
now bringing them inside the chamber I
suppose illegally yes to make a
political point the White House will
push back in part by having ice agents
in the chamber
to say these are some of the folks that
Democrats have said they wanted to
obliterate they want to get rid of these
everybody washing to make straightfoward
points anymore of a policy or is
everything a symbolic display it's
pretty rare as you know I mean in fact
we have this bipartisan conference
committee that's supposed to solve all
the problems around immigration they've
met once maybe twice they initially the
Democrats there said everything is on
the table that was the quote of the
democratic chair Nina LOI
within about 24 hours the Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi hill you see front
senator said walls not on the table no
money for the wall so so to your
question about symbolism they say
everything's on the table on immigration
and border security and within 24 hours
and speaker the house says no and Henry
thank you for that pretty so nice as
always